[Aplausos]
actualmente nos dedicamos a la
organización del festival de fotografía
internacional ya conocido porque es un
evento que se hace año con año y
obviamente tratamos temáticas y
actividades a este arte que es la
fotografía español ya llegamos a nuestra
quinta edición de manera consecutiva
conceptual también al algo del año pues
tenemos diversas actividades y talleres
y diplomados para algunos de ellos bueno
cuando conozco alguna alguna persona que
no estamos presentando me preguntan a
qué me dedico esto y bueno cuando se
pregunta cómo es que el fiel como se te
ocurrió y bueno pues el fiel surgió
gracias acepte lo que aquí la mayoría de
los proyectos también gracias a pepe en
mi caso es hace tiempo y profesión
mis pasatiempos desde muy pequeño ha
gustado muchísimo rivales y los retos
tales
fotografía pintura y la profesión van al
médico también a la fotografía
aquí mi primer tipo es hacer lo que nos
gusta
hay que hacer lo que queremos hacer y
pasarlo por pasión y no un principio es
por dinero el dinero yo creo que
vamos a servir las cosas ayudando
un ejemplo claro
y una fotografía y retoque hace un par
de años
vaya paddle
mil dólares
bueno si por ahí dijeron la famosa
cantidad de 0 pez y porque bueno en
primera porque la night and night o me
contrató para hacer esta fotografía una
fotografía que yo hice por mero gusto es
una fotografía que yo le diría
espontánea nuestra fotografía ello
planea de un día
productivo si está dando vueltas aquí
vamos a ponernos red y en esa noche
bueno esa madrugada el reto de hacer una
fotografía con lo que tenía en casa a la
mano no estaba en el estudio en el
estudio pues la fotografía estaba en
casa y dije vamos a una foto con la mano
y como no tenía nada la mano
verán
la fotografía fue bueno pues digo como
un reto lo que me gustó para hacer algo
de madrugada me gustó la fotografía las
redes sociales la gente va a ver sus
orgasmos comentarios positivos unos de
ellos me preguntaban que cuando lo había
vendido lo que sin la night había sido
mi cliente y ya les contesté que es
porque no sé latentes
hemos visto publicidad
ya que esta publicidad de los consejos
volvía a subir la fotografía
y etiqueta nike con todos los hashtags
etiquetas que pude encontrar en hits
conectados y 2 william viernes de pintor
night lo que se les ocurra etiqueta por
donde pude y cual creen que fue la
sorpresa pues nada no pasó nada la nike
no le dio ni un like un corazón sin
tonium compartirá la foto de una
tristeza dibujada no pasó nada con la
nike pero qué pasó la gente que está
estamos en contacto en las redes
sociales y vi la fotografía y si tuvo
impacto en ellos
gracias a que yo subí a esta fotografía
que les digo
una planeada que gracias al estudiado a
diez cursos y ponente económicamente
contrariamente yo estoy seguro que ya
respiro más en lo que la night hubiera
pagado
les voy a poner otros casos de
fotógrafos que admiro muchísimo y que
han venido también a este festival de
fotografía la de este tipo de
fotografías con objetos o con modelos a
escala hasta clientes y bueno nosotros
como público y espectadores vemos la
fotografía y pensamos que es este audio
este caso ves
tamaño real
el mismo crea toda esta atmósfera y que
de igual manera en nuestras fotografías
las en las redes sociales
factor internacional y las empresas
hasta audi y otras más trabajo si algo
obvio
para el mismo está colaborando
empresas a nivel
otro fotógrafo del mar gómez
de fotografía youtube y él también
decidió hacer la fotografía las
lecciones de anatomía también la isla
pero gusto le gustó muchísimo el
resultado a nuestra fotografía a
suscribir la foto
propio mundial
excluye
la copa y bueno mando esta fotografía y
nada más y nada menos que quedó en
segundo lugar medalla de plata en la
categoría de ilustración
y ante karting el fotógrafo finlandés y
también el decidió hacer esta fotografía
con este niño
la fotografía
y obviamente ya después
la composición de edición
maravillosa
todos ellos y se fijan empezaron
haciendo algo para ellos mismos por
pasión no fue algo que entiendo se nos
haya pedido y pues el éxito que han
tenido en esta fotografía la copa
mundial también a pont en ese entonces y
pues se trajo la medalla de oro por
hacer algo que le gusta entonces aquí
siete hits o consejo ya vimos a pepe
ahora vemos aparte haz las cosas para ti
dale
lo tenemos que hacer siempre que estar
aunque trabajemos en alguna empresa o
freelance
para nosotros es bien importante
escucharnos muchas veces ya tenemos un
trabajo bien establecido
que se dedica a sociales
hay dinero pero yo estoy seguro de que
si ellos van hacer eso a la larga van a
ganar
para mí el arte y la fotografía en
general debe ser algo que no es un arte
cualquiera necesidad es una parte además
universal aquí en china podemos
disfrutar o entender o no entender
alguna obra no
salvo que ahora
nuestra propia traducción interpretación
algunos
triste y cada quien tiene su
interpretación no necesita estar al lado
y explicar que si es algo tan universal
es algo que se tiene que compartir el
arte
artistas
y este tipo de ejercicio para ayudar a
conocernos a nosotros mismos para poder
luego poder interactuar y vivir
aquí unas clases que les recomiendo
por ahí en la calle y es la fotografía
es cosa de suerte en general yo yo creo
que la suerte no existe existe yo creo
que causalidades del tiempo espacio todo
esto pero la suerte en sí no existe y
esta es una de las fotografías que
cualquier punto grafo cualquier persona
podría decir que es fue cosa de suerte
el descripción tapiró fotógrafo de
colima él con esta fotografía ganó el
corazón el año national geographic
wordpress foto y nuestra fotografía y
y entonces
pero no sabía la naturaleza no sabemos
si va a ser hoy a las 5 de la mañana
pero él estuvo un mes esperando este
momento esperando esta fotografía y de
hecho él había aquí va a ver actividad
pero no sabía cómo se iba a comportar el
portal
pero las iba a salir un rayo va a salir
la va a pasar y es por eso que él puso
de hecho varias cámaras y
simultáneamente se estaban tomando otros
en diferentes lugares con diferentes
valores cada cámara porque positivo no
sabes qué va a pasar
ganador de varios premios y les digo si
no hubiera sido por la observación toda
la perseverancia la disciplina no
hubiera podido lograr esto
quiero ver a alguien que le diga que
este es corto
una foto
otra cosa para cualquiera tomar buenas
fotografías yo creo que siempre lo hemos
escuchado y vemos a nuestro primo que se
compró una cámara de 100 mil pesos o
millones de lo que quiera
y pues esta es una fotografía que tomé
hace unos 10 años
para mí una fotografía
supervalu ni extraordinaria pero mi vida
en la vida dentro de la fotografía me
marcó mucho en primera
de la geografía que salió en la portada
efe
extra y es el camino a seguir por aquí y
la otra lo contrario a la frase que les
decía esta fotografía la tomé con una
camarita y versión de bolsillo nuestras
tiras cuando va de viaje
que tenía 8 megapíxeles les apuesto que
la mayoría de los nenes
a cámara
es bueno también para mí fue ahora con
lo que tienes aunque sea su perito hay
que hacer algo para lo que la
a por aquí la siguiente frase que es
algo que sí le debes decir un fotógrafo
y el componente más importante de una
cámara a detrás de él
está en nuestros productos y pensé los
prejuicios de que si no tienes la super
cámara te vale tanto mil pesos por
dólares vas a tomar una buena foto hay
que estarla
persiguiendo
algo que se ha pasado a la gran mayoría
de grandes sueños play consigo grandes
sacrificios cuantas fotografías creen
que un fotógrafo para él
a que no
vamos a decir número super bajitos una
foto por mes
para que sea
al azar vamos a decir 12 fotos por mes
cuántas creen que yo he hecho a lo largo
de este mes
pero fotografías
vamos a ver un poquito optimistas
pero significa 5 fotos ni la mitad de un
fotógrafo promedio debe tomar por año
es un gran sacrificio que en este caso
yo como fotógrafo pues les va a ser por
apostarle también a otros sueños es
decir que no vaya a ser fotografía
espero pronto regresar para ahorita
estoy tomando otro camino
grandes sueños lario la parte
cambios recompensas tanto colectivas
como individuales
posición al festival desde la primera
edición entre los cinco mejores de
méxico
pero cumple más sueño sabiendo los
encaminados
en el 2018 recibimos el premio fotógrafo
el año
por qué
y digo recibimos por
entregaron a mí su premio y yo lo veo de
público hecho este es un premio es a
través de la votación pública
la gente puede decidir y votar
favorito en este año lectivo
autor hieron
año pasado el portal del framework
market éxito entre los fotógrafos
destacan 13 años de todo méxico y el
estar no gracias
y no reemplacen muchísimo
en realidad son sueños que inicialmente
es un sueño que va generando una serie
de conexiones
conocer a otros fotógrafos digo la
fotografía o el arte debe ser algo que
no se aprovecha por las redes sociales y
la tecnología que existe para unirnos
para compartir es algo instantáneo no
quiere decir que sea malo
para
a perder el tiempo pero hay que sacarle
provecho a lo que parece
viajar a otros países a través de la
fotografía conocer otras culturas otras
personas
y otras maneras de vivir dav
las puertas a transmitir conocimientos a
través de talleres con otras personas
regresamos de cuba de impartir este
taller gracias
ver cumplidos los sueños de otras
personas por qué es
tenemos
en el lugar
algo bastante bueno para
empieza a abrir puertas el metió la
misma factura
a otro concurso de sodio
entonces
pues qué padre que nosotros hacemos
grande estable
sueño personal se convierte en un sueño
colectivo uno de los más grandes sueños
es el poder trabajar al lado de mi
familia
y papá
se fijan somos una familia pequeña
y va a estallar ya la pequeña pero esta
familia pequeña se ha convertido en todo
esto y se dice que un artista
y
[Aplausos]